yaw antwi aujourd'hui on se retrouve sur
un pee wees parce que ça fait pas loin
d'un an qu'on n'a pas fait le duo là
dessus et que cette femme me manquer
c'est faux pokémon ques niveau s'appelle
oh mon dieu
haro cops sauvage se fait capturer waouh
incroyable ah c'est beaucoup moins
croyable ça cette fois ça ne se passera
pas comme ça
non moi je suis mort faisant un gros
plus tôt un pokémon donc vraiment très
heureux quand je met une faute mais non
mais non non ok disparition disparition
dans l'arbre mais d'aplomb lacombe tenir
tu es censé me lâcher plus tard lâche
moi bloche voiloche mois pouvez-vous
survivre à nomeny quel nom on n'était
pas note 5 sites a survécu ou note 4 si
tu es mort ah oui le cléac'h ok oui
effectivement effet eu un problème
oui oui non oui elle est belle
ah non ça va être sur la non et will be
okei okei ce qui élimine voilà pas comme
ça par exemple est dehors et data on
s'en fout des fils ton nom est de 1 et
de 2 et 3 ans je me suis débrouillé vous
avez ce qu'on avait fait on avait fait 1
2 pas comme ça quand je n'ai pu tester
plus la peine de s'acharner sur mon
canap [ __ ] attendez vous avez on peut
s'envoler un petit peu comme dans un
étier regarder si on fait ça oh arrêtez
de donner de faux espoirs à temps et
sucé manière correcte pédaler ça oui tu
t'en vas tu te tombent au label elle est
moins belle mais au moins on et voilà on
a faim on brode quoi bon dernière et
c'est chez parce que tu tentes et
c'était bien de la merde oui si tout
baigne ou excite tous mais nous pourrons
s'en fou pour exciter tout manu
finalement on salue manu sword trop hard
ça j'adore ces niveaux faut lancer les
effets il me semble vous avez peut-être
pris très cher un mois l'eurobond
syndrome ondimba dont je sais juste
qu'il attrape celle vraiment au voit la
paille tout ça à chaque fois on met
toutes lés p sur ce pauvre garçon quoi
mais je suis bien je suis bien à soi
paddec j'aime bien regarder c'est parti
oui ou non non non je suis dit ok nickel
quoi au fait mais la demande est ce bon
vieux en bas et se reprend en fait ce
qui est dur c'est de choper le sable
tout là-haut assez bon on l'a eu désolé
attendait juste malté mohr
on était assis volontairement sur un
sable quoi alors si tu aimes ça tu nous
dis il n'y a pas de problème voilà quoi
[ __ ] on n'a qu'une chance ça change
notre vie n'en tombe non mais [ __ ] ça
ça me regarde nos vidéos il est regardé
il s'est il est adepte de la pression
foetus et regarder sauf que là ça nous a
carrément bon et que c'est tout mais new
to man u c'est lui manu pouvez vous le
faire pas tant que ça oui à pas loin
ah oui elle est belle sauf pour cent il
possible 1-1 rêver comme ça tombait
comme si ce n'est pas déjà assez
douloureux de se prendre une fois
regarder ce qui fait quoi le truc vibre
dans mes fesses arrêté je vais y arriver
ça touche beaucoup pourraient provoquer
et non mais bien tenté mais non non mais
bien tenté bien tenté mais non non mais
attends mais c'est juste millions au
courant en temps d en citer des noms
plus clair pour de thaler qui arrive
droit dans mon cul on est bon allez
salut fis pouvez vous gagnez oui oui
échappez vous de la boîte break the
glass je suis comment casta glace vite
au goût du jour la casse et on s'échappe
oui merci fiston tu prends tout pour moi
c'est très gentil t'en fais pas ça va
aller jack on l'appelait à au revoir
jack jack oui tu dis actualité arriver
les choses que moi finalement t'en fais
pas ça va aller cette fois agence eut
privé une [ __ ] t'as mal fait ton
boulot jack tu vas crever [ __ ] bâtons
rompus au revoir papa je t'aime on a
réussi jack jack
à bientôt jack o et j'ai perdu mon
casque nomade encore non non tu voulais
tant d'années tu ne reviendra jamais
jack ary chalus position je crois que
j'ai sur toi jacques ça suffit rien je
suis mort faut qu'elle se casse jack
patachon je parlais du verre [ __ ]
enfilé vous non
à au plus haut point le chef est tiré il
s'occupait encore quoi je suis bien avec
mes pieds vraiment au groupe b avec un
road trip en voiture un samedi smadja
bleu presque penser marche pas donc je
dois avancer comme ça que mamady ce cas
roman original l'amusement est vraiment
présent lorsque j'arrive soudainement
sur une balançoire avec des enfants mais
je ne les écrase pas je les esquives
bien sûr je les esquives comme il se
doit un restaurant j'esquive toujours
vous me connaissez maintenant et voilà
on a fait notre bonne action du jour euh
non non pas cette position priest ou
nickels nickel j'ai envie de tout mais
c'est totalement faux foetus une grosse
mer vers la haye
j'adore mes jeux juste cassé un orteil
il y en a à [ __ ] quoi hop là il va
tomber il tangue
ils essaient pourriez tomber mais
apprécie les patentes ils ont foiré vite
à aa il est tombé apparemment c est
impossible
rien est impossible pour nous c'est donc
ce que j'ai fait il faut que j'aille la
win win pas la def
ça fait défier la mort est ce que je la
laisse entrer ce
ceci est dur j'adore le nous est très
vendeur déjà au nom mais pas ça bah
voilà où la difficulté au church il
s'envole
il aimait les vigneaux il sera vu en
vidéo jag bon alors on va faire le
travail nous-mêmes
bon en charge au niveau alors déjà à au
22 mai qu'il allait dans les dires de
niveau on peut le dire hier prison
clavier il a fait un truc comme ça alors
fait quoi wait to the bonus j'attends
une position peu confortable
ok très bien est ce qu'on rigole non
mais parfois le magazine y voir des amis
exilés vous avez c'était drôle non ce
n'est pas dans le but un ultra ninja
training
bienvenue dans mon niveau n'y voit la
balle qui tombe allez vous encore bien
joué niveau 2 les vitres qui se brise a
alors on est des ninjas ou [ __ ] on
passera on ira sauver nos diplômes de
ninja niveau 3 qu'ils aiment au taux bas
pour aller défoncer au bengladesh qui
est longue avec touchant
tiens tiens oh c'était beau qu'est ce
qui se passe et moi la victorie c'est
mon nouveau pays c'est alors j'aimerais
un jour m'envoler telle une offre énorme
et j'ai perdu mon casque jack mais le
casque jack mélo dans ta tête [ __ ]
mais le casque enfin papa au revoir jack
je t'envoie which agouazi jack cette
fois tout hacker mon gars bon sénat faut
tout d une info de pardon à l'étiage
basses
vas-y tu y vas jack c'est bon alors fly
président and grab the sword mponyo
renaît ben oui là on a eu avec le piège
c'est plutôt le turbo matin c'était
n'importe quoi c'est pas mal ce niveau
j'aime beaucoup mais j'aimerais bien
vraiment attraper le pecq ma main avec
mon cul [ __ ] mais qu'est ce qu'elle
est beaucoup
il faut juste y arrive à prendre les
pays tu es mort cette fois je te tuerais
tu as tué ma femme comme c'est beau je
suis là avec le genou comme ça sur
source agresse un train de faire la tête
sur la tête sur sa calvitie et je lui
dis alors on n'a pas mis d'après
shampoing oui mais voilà cher c'est la
fin de cette vidéo sur happy with it has
vous aura plu ça fait plaisir de refaire
un petit pas sur ce jeu ça faisait
vraiment longtemps qu'on n'y avait pas
joué il ya toujours autant d'évocations
créé tous les jours plus fous les uns
que les autres ça fait vraiment plaisir
à voir le jeu ne meurt pas du tout mais
c'est d'avoir gardé ont surtout retrouvé
dans une nouvelle vidéo tient du monde
pis
[Musique]